we need all available guards in full
combat gear
[Music]
spare me your style case woman
why is this one here we promised him he
could stay by your side until he kills
your boss I always keep my promises when
they're at a muscle down whack jobs will
kill me if I don't here you go
oh I was just kidding about the leg I
just need these two things what no I
thought it'd be funny wasn't funny no
wait what did he look like hopping
around I had to transfer him 30 000
units
how are we gonna leave
but he's got a plan right or is that
another thing you made up I have a plan
I have a plan since you're yammering it
would leave us from this hurts we can
find them yeah I'll have to agree with
The Walking thesaurus on that one
do not ever call me at the source
just a metaphor dude his people are
completely literally metaphors are going
to go over his head nothing goes over my
head my reflexes are too fast I would
catch it
surrounded by
[Music]
those are some big guns
oh my come on number one
Ronin we are ready for your plan
I recognize this animal
we'd rush them over a flame to those
children because it's quite delicious
not healthy number three
[Music]
all fire oh my come on
he turned off the artificial gravity
everywhere but in here
foreign
[Music]
files
that was a pretty good plan huh